Julian we're here to talk about well so
many things that you've done over the
years I mean you've been in so many
franchises bonds even in Harry Potter
you've been in Doctor Who you know in
Game of Thrones Court also had her your
eyes only yeah so so the Star Wars
Indiana Jones we don't we see a
continent I think I'm the only actor
who's been in all these franchises it's
now four if you count Harry Potter which
I was only a voice but it's five now
with them Game of Thrones which is
turning into yet another great
blockbuster of a series and which is
very gratifying I think I'm the only
actor who's been in all of them playing
the master talking about Game of Thrones
though well it's like playing him it's
actually it's not very comfortable
although I don't have a wig on thank God
I do have that itchy beard which they
and the makeup man takes the moustache
off every lunchtime so I can have enjoy
my meal I don't
and the costume is rather uncomfortable
it's very we were just filming in
Dubrovnik few weeks a couple of weeks
ago it was really hot and my costume is
thick heavy velvet and long folds of it
and a the whatever it is around the neck
the great big chain thing is really
heavy it's so heavy that it hangs here
but it has to be tied I have a wrestlers
belt on underneath my costume really
tight and that's tied up that the the
chain thing is hot tied onto that to
take the weight so it's um if you'll
excuse me it's like having a very big
bosom hanging on your shoulder and well
so it's not very comfortable I love
working on with the people and I love
playing him he's such a bad boy
this is great survivor he's a little bit
different how you how he used the stone
in the TV series than he is in the books
isn't he and I believe that that's to do
with you isn't it tell me a little bit
about that well yes you're obviously
know but um I've done about three
episodes of it and I got pretty bored
playing isn't playing an old man who
sits at the table but I went to the
writers now so he's a very modest table
me I said look I'm a better actor than
this you misused me and give me
something and they went away and they
brought up what I do which is I'm
covering up I'm playing a very very very
old man in a cell and is protective it
means I don't get killed and I never I
was back the right horse at any
particular time which is very clever of
him and they got the idea from when we
were filming and they'd say turn over
and I'd go down into my old man pose and
I'd do the scene and then cut and I'd
stand up again I thought ah that's a
good idea because Julian's not like that
he cried a vigorous old man Julian and
so that's what they wrote and during his
first that is virtually I've just played
a couple of very nice scenes in the
series three about being Oh about not
being as old as I seem kind of a little
bit secretive and hiding things then yes
that's absolutely is a American say that
Tywin sausage Meowth says how long
you've been getting away with this for
years
it's ridiculous why do you do it I say
to survive I virtually say I want to die
in my own time not somebody else's
alright you know my time will come very
soon because I'm very old but because
I'm 104 for God's sake a very long life
expectancy and and he accepts that and
he he acts accordingly I won't tell you
anymore you can have quite a run in the
TV series and I can make out from from
the books as well you're looking forward
to that I hope so I know I'm in the next
the next series
which we start filming in July I think I
don't know how much I'm gonna be in I
wasn't in nearly enough in the last one
right but I'm still there and I spoke to
the writers and said I do survive do I
enter oh yes yes yes they said but don't
worry I said when you when you do die if
you dude I wish we don't know yet
don't worry it'll be a good death so I
expect something spectacular you wait
till you see how Charlie dance dies that
is really funny and of course I'm not
going to tell you how would you how
would you like to die how would you have
a kind of imagination that led you to
places and things that would happen it's
got to be really dramatic it's I would
prefer him just to die in his bed and
for people to regret that his died and
to think well he was quite a useful
fella because he he is been he's he
always backs the king and they he backs
the King and that's it
and he's bloody useful to the older
kings and you know you had a scene in
the last series when with Tyrion when
Tyrion puts him in prison and all that
stuff
I like the idea of him being sexually
vigorous still and having a private life
which is his own it needs to be as well
I only say the death I would like to be
as interesting as Charlie dances
I don't want simply a decapitation or
something like that which we've done
those I want it to be as interesting as
that so that I could actually so I got
an opportunity to play it rather than
just because I would like to be able to
play my death so but we'll see maybe I
meant something first also look forward
to there you go well Charles said of
course you've worked with him over the
years haven't you broke memorably as
well in bond your your eyes only
yes I'm not sure we met on that actually
but I've known him since nineteen where
the mid-70s late seventies when we were
both with the Royal Shakespeare Company
together and we played brothers in one
play and he understudied me in another
play well now he's a big film star we
get on very well indeed he's a I was
filming with him in Dubrovnik a few
weeks ago and got on very well indeed
good good man good man very handsome man
what's it like being out there at
filming in Croatia what it was wonder I
was only there three days but filming in
Dubrovnik which is just one of the most
beautiful places in the whole world what
is it like being on location as an actor
what does that give you rather than just
being in a studio somewhere Oh
locations are always much better unless
you get surrounded by people who go at
you
well yes over here on our location
you've got so much atmosphere which is
given to you without you having to do
any work
we were in Dubrovnik on this beautiful
beach with this wonderful castle behind
us and it was it was so lovely excuse me
and we didn't look at the tourists who
were looking at us over the wall could
we were looking at to see and it was
beautiful sea and the Sun and Oh
uncomfortable because of the costume but
you know I don't I didn't have to join
did I but some sometimes it's it's it
can be off-putting I remember many years
of doing things during a film called qb7
which was a three-part television series
very very serious stuff and we filmed
part of it in a a one-time concentration
camp in Belgium which was not a murder
camp but it was a torture camp and
anyway doesn't matter what he was and we
filmed there on a Sunday
so that there would be less people but
they still let the public in and the
public were far more interested in us
than they were in watching nothing
happening on a film because as you know
in our film said nothing happens much
more interesting at us than they were in
looking at this horrifying place means
the second you know kind of fans and
having people look at you when you're on
location and various things there's
obviously the shows with drones got lots
and lots of fans why do you think people
what do you think people think why do
you think people think of your character
in particular I don't know what they
think I've noticed done on occasions
like this this convention that people
rather like him because he's such a
scallywag know that this pretend game is
playing all the time and now that people
know he is playing a game they see me in
a different light I'm not which is very
satisfactory to me which is what I asked
for I'm not just a very old man who
gives advice I'm someone who's a rather
more interesting than that and then
people buy my photograph say oh I love
him I love old pycelle who's here such
as Connie wacko mind everyone has got a
wagon that Sean beans about the only
nice person even tyrion who's so
fantastic what a wonderful actor he is
he can be pretty horrible - really
pretty horrible when it suits what he's
gonna have to do but on the other hand
his heart is always in the right place
Tyrion is there and he uses it the fact
that he's a small person and mind you
there are some developments coming up
with you know nothing about which are
going to be very interested in now I'm
not saying absolutely did you know the
books at all before you came to the show
I have a ruler I shall read them when we
finish when world one I'm finished I
have a rule about that with fictional
stories not with real characters who
actually lived I read up on those like
man like I played a Dubcek of
Czechoslovakia and I read everything I
could find about him and went and met
him and anyway but fiction I think well
the people have adapted the script if I
like the script
do the script don't go back to the book
and say oh why haven't we got that bit
in that bit would be good oh but we
don't need to do that bit that's this
little bit better
it's a bloody nuisance for the people
who have written that I've made their
choices and so I consciously as I say
don't read the books with fiction and I
think that's paid off in this one
because as you pointed out I've built on
but he goes on and on but he's not very
significant in the book he's just there
and contributes now and again but now as
I keep on saying he's much more
interesting yeah are you looking forward
to reading the books when you do
eventually finish and also what does
George Martin think of the way your
characters developed well he like he
likes it he he'd had to be put to him of
course when the writers got the idea
they had to call him up in the States
and put the idea I don't know how they
put it I should think they said you know
I think they did echo what I said sorry
I'm too good an actor they did waste me
and
I was playing a fine old daughter over
and now they know why I'm like I am why
why I'm that sort of daughter you know
my wife said I'm actually engaged I'm
doing a play at the moment when I play
someone of 90 and it's a great mistake
to play old man to play an old man just
beat you know if you don't know you're
90 they'll know you're 90
those old pycelle he's acting being 98
being a hundred and four so that's a
much more interesting thing to do when
is finished I shall read the books it's
as simple as that because I shall be
very interested to see about everybody
else quite often you know you read a
script and you have no idea what's going
to happen when I read the script of
episode 9 of the first series when Shawn
gets it I got to the end a head chopped
off I thought no no no no you don't kill
off Hamlet in the middle of the play
scene
so I went right back to the script and
read it really properly because I
thought I must have missed something
yeah no I hadn't missed anything at all
because his head chopped off one of the
bravest things I've ever known on
television and they had the courage to
chop his head off and go on with a
series and of course I mean that that
the character the name of the character
lives on because you know that chat
would always be around in people's minds
either as a threat or someone who was
very good and to have that sort of
enormous figure chopped in the first
series but they had the courage to go on
with it and now look at it it says you
can't stop it it's a roller coaster and
I see no reason why it shouldn't go on
right from the end of the sixth book or
maybe you can write another one you know
because it's timeless as we know people
come and people go mostly people go
amazing piece of imagination the whole
thing in the fact that it isn't in a
particular period it's just got every
period that ever happened is in it
they don't have pinstripe suits but you
know it I mean and all the artifacts and
things come from every period in history
and from all over the world and the idea
of that I swore in the very very first
episode when we went to see the first
showing of the first episode we had no
idea what it was going to look like and
that I swore presented itself beginning
that little hole in the back bottom of
it
with the people coming out on their
horses oh my god what a piece of
imagination and the idea having two
separate parts of England which is such
a small island
perpetually at odds with each other and
completely different sorts of people
because of the weather
it's so wonderful idea wonderful idea so
imaginative are these some of the
reasons you think why this show has been
such an enormous success well I mean
that's one of the reasons it's a
brilliant story it's very well
photographed and nowadays they can set
shoot as much material as they like we
could it's all done electronically
because when I first started filming it
was all on film and producers would come
along to a director and say aha
no more takes on this one no more takes
this is fine because cost so much in
film
well they don't have to do that anymore
so you know sometimes we come off at the
end of the scene huh
god they shot that scene to death but
they always find the wonderful bits of
it to show you and very well edited and
series of very professional directors
never the same well directors vary
according to each episode as you must
know and and now the writers have
started directing themselves which is
yes which is terrific because they know
what they want to say but as a viewer of
the show which are your favorite
characters Oh Tyrion
Tyrian of go no further
you know it he's the guy I always
delight when I see him when I watch him
working when I'm in a scene with him or
watch him on the screen he says you go
ah yes
wonderful actor wonderful actor
you